[Musique]
il y à 70 ans david ben gourion
proclamer la création de l'état d'israël
pour celles et ceux qui avaient entendu
théodore hertzl théorisé l'état des
juifs 50 ans auparavant pour ceux peu
nombreux qu'ils avaient échappé à la
shoah il y avait ce jour là un immense
espoir une délivrance est un
accomplissement
nous aurions aimé retrouver cette
atmosphère au lieu de cela depuis hier
nous avons en mémoire des images
difficiles de morts par dizaines et deux
blessés par milliers au moment même où
était inaugurée à jérusalem
l'ambassade des états unis monsieur le
premier ministre
quelles initiatives la france peut-elle
encore engagées pour retrouver dans
cette région tourmentée qui peut
s'embraser à tout moment le chemin de la
paix je vous remercie
la journée d'hier à gaza a été la plus
meurtrière depuis 2014 avec près de 60
morts
démineurs et près de 2700 blessés dont
beaucoup par balles la france condamne
évidemment est sans aucune ambiguïté ces
violences
car si nous sommes sans aucune ambiguïté
attachés à la sécurité d'israël
nous ne pouvons pas accepter un tel
niveau de violence face au droit
fondamental des palestiniens à
manifester pacifiquement le politique de
la france elle est connue elle est
ancienne elle a pour objectif deux états
israël et la palestine vivant dans la
paix et la sécurité au sein de
frontières reconnues avec jérusalem pour
capitale des deux états c'est ce que dit
le droit
c'est la ligne défendue par la fatigue
dimanche la barbarie islamiste a volé la
vie d'un jeune homme de 29 ans l'horreur
se répète un attentat de plus qui a
donné lieu à de grandes et belles
phrases un philosophe a parlé de
sidération rituel la consternation les
indignation légitime ne sont plus
suffisantes
on a le sentiment que l'accoutumance ou
terrorisme islamiste nous guette
or il ya pire que l'horreur il y à
l'accoutumance à l'horreur les réponses
au terrorisme ne sont bien sûr technique
la qualité du travail des forces de
l'ordre et du renseignement mérite
d'être salué mais une vraie réponse
passe aussi et surtout si l'on veut agir
à long terme par un réarmement moral et
culturel de notre pays nous ne réglerons
pas la question des attentats si nous
laissons des quartiers entiers de notre
territoire réchappe échapper aux lois de
la république
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le premier
ministre il est temps pour la france de
déclarer l'état d'urgence culturelle et
morale
oui il faut combattre idéologiquement ce
terrorisme
cet islamisme radical qui amène à tuer
dans nos quartiers il faut peut-être
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas dans
nos grandes villes à la fois des
endroits prospère et puis des cartes et
qui se paupérise qui se ghettoïse parce
que à force de vivre côte à côte en
finit un jour par vivre face à face
alors oui la lutte doit être menée sur
tous les plans à la fois par l'action
policière et en même temps par l'action
culturelle par la bataille
intellectuelle et c'est tous ensemble
que nous devons la gagner
[Musique]